jessica how's it going well i'm 21
and my boyfriend is 35. all right
my um my dad is worried about it
and um i'm questioning whether or not i
should continue this relationship
why are you questioning it
because i um i really care
about my family i really love my family
and
i don't want to cause any problems i'm
very happy
with my boyfriend we we train for a
marathon together we serve our church
together
but i also wouldn't want to cause any
problems with my family
so who do you this is not a fair
question who do you love more your
family or
your 35 year old boyfriend my family
ooh good job that's a good answer by the
way and that's not a fair question
i mostly asked that question just for my
own um just to have some fun
with my own so on my own so
what is your dad when he expresses
concern about this dude what does he say
he says things like um you know he's
eight years younger than me
and he also has a 11 year old daughter
and he'll say you know she is half your
age
um i think he's worried about it because
he cares about me
and it makes me question the
relationship also
and so when you question the
relationship what are the questions
going into your mind
i think about if i'm making the right
decision
by continuing the relationship
what's the rush
um and i asked that question here what's
what's like dating somebody
are you are you on sort of some sort of
decision precipice is he asking you to
marry him
are you um feeling like it's now or
never
i i don't understand you're 21 you're
you're
just a baby baby girl you're just a
beautiful baby girl and you're 21 like
you're just dating somebody having a
good time
why why do you feel discomfort at this
point
i think i feel more discomfort because
we we have been talking about future
things
um okay so it's getting more serious
yes gotcha and so
here's the thing your dad's gonna
struggle with you being his child
versus you being a 21 year old adult
that's normal dad's loving their
daughters dads loving their sons
moms loving their sons moms and sons are
sometimes the worst but
moms and their daughters you're 21 and
so you're in that wackadoo area
where your dad still looks at you as
though you're 13 you think you're 47
and neither of those things are true
right the other side of it is you're
going to struggle with taking anyone's
wisdom because you're 21
and you think you're super smart and
you've got it all figured out
and you love him and he's so cute and he
loves god
and he loves running and he's such a
good dad all those things right that
make you feel good
and so um if you like this guy and you
like hanging out with him i say keep
hanging out with him
if you value your dad's opinion then
break up with him
and so when i say either of those things
what do you feel
i feel like i value my dad's opinion
more
why is that
because i feel like he
i don't know he's the first boyfriend
i've had and i'm
just kind of i feel like i don't really
need to be dating anyone right now
sir are you calling me with permission
to break up with him
no okay are you calling me with
permission to tell your dad hey i'm 21
and i like a guy and it's a little
unconventional and y'all are old enough
to be buddies but
shake it off i like this dude and we're
just seeing where it goes
are you calling me permission for that
i will yes i would like to see where it
goes okay
so distill all of your the the thoughts
in your mind
the whose side are you on what team are
you on to distill that down into a
single question for me
[Music]
um
i want to respect my best decisions also
finding out where this relationship can
go
sure this dude's 35 has he ever taken
your dad out for a drink or for coffee
and just hung out and said hey
here's my intentions with dating your
daughter have they ever just
met together he hasn't
why not um
my boyfriend hasn't invited him to do
anything like that and my dad hasn't
either
hmm so here's what i would recommend
number one
you're a grown-up you can do what you
want to do
at some point you're gonna have wishes
about your life
whether it's having kids whether it's
naming your child whether it's moving
away out of utah
to arkansas or to florida or to ireland
there's gonna be things that come up in
your adult life that your dad has an
opinion on that you're gonna disagree
with him
and so you're gonna have to start
drawing boundaries and respect your dad
obviously if he's a good guy you seem to
love him and he cares about you
and you get that but then at some point
you're gonna have to make your own
decisions
and as a as an adult the other side of
that is
i just hear in your voice that you
maybe think he's right on this one and
maybe you really like this guy it's cool
but maybe dad's right and so i
i still get wisdom from my old man i
don't do everything that he tells me in
fact i do very little of what he tells
me but i value his opinion greatly
because he's seen things
and he understands things and he just
got a different worldview than i do and
i like collecting different world views
my suggestion is if this guy really
likes you he needs to take your dad out
they need to go get a drink somewhere go
grab a beer go grab some coffee
and just get to know each other and let
your dad ask him all the hard questions
your dad i promise you has had a million
fake conversations with this guy
if i just get him they've already had
these conversations over and over again
in his head just not in real life
and your boyfriend may have had these
conversations with him
if he really is invested in you he's
going to be invested in your family
because you marry the whole thing
and so i recommend he'd be a grown man
he's 35 years old take your dad out
go hang out and get to know each other
and then they can have that conversation
he may come back to you and be like hey
by the way we're breaking up i don't
like you anymore
after meeting with your dad or your dad
may come back and say hey
this is weird he's 14 15 years older
than you
it's not it doesn't make me comfortable
but if that's who you like that's who
you like
and dad's gonna have to deal but at the
end of the day
you're 21 you're an adult by all legal
definitions
not psychologically but you're an adult
and at the end
you're going to start making adult
decisions and some of those decisions
are going to make your dad uncomfortable
and you're going to be okay with that
but you've got my permission to do
whatever you want to do if he's a good
guy and he treats you well
and you are safe and you are having fun
with life then
keep dating him and if you think this
isn't a good idea my dad's got my best
interest at heart and man
i should listen to my old man then break
up with him or
just be 21 and enjoy your life have fun
it's a little bit different he's got a
11 year old daughter um
and so there's a little more pressure
there as some as you're dating somebody
but man
don't you're 21 years old you're a kid
and i don't mean that mean but you're a
kid enjoy your life
enjoy your life